we have the portuguese uh gambit right with knight
f6 here to hit the pawn on d5 yeah but do do they
know it's the portuguese gambit is really the
question is this preparation or is this just
a little bit of inspiration over the board
because um it must be you know this must
be i don't mind it's fine let's not overthink it
tim yeah if we go up middle we both trade i lose
a little bit based on development but that's
the opening that you chose so it's no problem
uh i think you were right it looks like prep
it looks like he set out to play the portuguese
gambit to attack felix's queen yeah and it makes
sense i think certainly he is the underdog um so
i i do like the idea of trying to go for something
early again i felt that in all the matches where
the players sort of the stronger players um
outshine their opponents was in the middle game
or the end game when when it got deeper and deeper
into the game and they just they weren't able to
come up with the concepts as easily so i think
the opening phase is the most important phase
um for the weaker players with players who are
perceived to be the weaker players in terms of
the uh the match match setup for rubios it's
very tricky too because the ideas here are not
obvious h5 and f5 don't seem very logical based
if you're just if you're just getting um getting
used to uh getting getting used to chess so it
seems like moves that are not not so um so common
in a sense at the same time you've done all the
basics you've developed and you've gotten your
king out knight before however is not a move that
i would have played now i'm a little bit concerned
if xqc castles the king here i think he's actually
quite a bit better having said that knight takes
c2 would completely explode the position because
he'll also win the d3 pawn so something like
this this and then bishop takes and then
xqc is not going to be able to castle short
so then then i don't know man then i don't
know it's gonna get it goes e4 whoa okay
so i think x x q c will probably take the knight
here as my guess because he'll see that pawn takes
his bad because he's going to be worried about
these tactics on uh with the pawn next to his
queen and the fork ideas so i think he probably
will take the knight here check all right take
he's calculating i can take rock and push
if i take
he's only looking at this deep
one right now if i take take
i'll take queen takes
i don't think he's realizing he actually can
take that knight and then take back on f3
this is very annoying this is very annoying the
thing at the moment please stop i actually stopped
dude so let's analyze why specifically the move
d4 led to such a massive drop-off it's because
when pawn takes f3 happen cicara i'm assuming you
can no longer take the knight because g2 correct
but again he takes on f3 i mean so far
everything rubius has done has been very
very impressive xvc has to take with the bishop
i feel like xc is a little bit nervous actually
it seems like he's nervous and he's not really
sure of himself in the way that he needs to be
um because some of these moves
like d4 are very very unusual
from him oh well hey cara this was expected
after yesterday but we've just crossed a
hundred thousand viewer threshold we're
at a hundred and one thousand viewers so
shout out to each and every one of you
so much love thank you all for being here wow
this is crazy what we're seeing so far i mean
in terms of the audience it's amazing in terms
of the chess this is uh this is off to a very
very bad start for xqc that being said the one
good thing however is that the pawn on a7 is
under attack that's the one good thing for x you
see here yes so i think i mean again i think the
problem for xqc is he's also down on time that's
actually the biggest issue that he has here
is not not even not even um the specific position
but the fact that he's down a minute on the clock
however i do know when i when i was um when
i was doing stuff with with rubius when we
did the collaboration he was also very slow and
when he got low on time he was also panicking a
little bit so if rubius is not able to keep this
big time advantage um i could see i could see uh
potentially some nerves and get getting worried um
also oh we've wondered [ __ ] f5 oh boy oh wow oh
just chill out for a second not too long
because he only has a minute and five seconds
get his rook to safety and pushes other
pawns right i mean again this is a very
hard position i think for both players to play
at this point um the good thing for xcc though
i think it's he should i mean bishop g5 is the
move that i think he might play here actually but
i don't i i wonder i think he's
going to go bishop g5 just to guess
oh my gosh that's such a stressful move man
just a guess just again oh that's probably
wrong but it's just it's just a guess
yeah you haven't been wrong yet so but i
oh my gosh actually he's got 30 seconds he's
also got to just move yeah just just go as far
away as possible don't even think about it rook a7
keep the king cut off oh my god how did you know
i told you i didn't feel like this
was gonna happen are you kidding me
not the best move but it's okay
dude you're a genius
oh i [ __ ] up he's just gonna discover
does he have any discovery here no it doesn't i'm
still good to go i could put that bit away but i
should just disengage that rook d5 is a great
move though great move by rubius fantastic move
one minute don't stop music sideways
checkmates one two three done so
come on you can swim over there if he wants
to write he can go to the right if he wants to
he saw the one square
check this is so epic
there's no stylemates here at least right there's
well there is one queen e6 is the only style mate
icarus stop stop it stop it he's done it yes wow
yes baby are we going to go to
the game you know what oh wow oh
see early game you don't do that it's a big
mistake that's terrible see what i did there good
job good job you you have him on the ropes you got
him on the [ __ ] ropes one more one more to go
he got all that hair off he lost all the brain
juice good [ __ ] job good [ __ ] joke let's go
let's go okay one more one more i mean yes made
no real mistakes pretty much picture perfect so
i think we've been underestimating um
underestimating rubies i think it's going to be
interesting to see because i'm very concerned uh
xqc's openings with black he's playing the petra
off again he's played this many many times um with
some very poor results so it's it it's quite scary
to see this opening occurring again and yeah
like i was saying what's amazed me so far is
how well all the players have done like in the
previous two editions there were always moments
where you you felt like certain players were
really mismatched and kind of very early on in
the game you felt like it was just like okay well
unfortunately for the players weaker they're just
you know they're they're not as strong they're
going to lose and it seems like in this event
every time every match has been really close
the openings have been very balanced um and
it's just great to see really really great to see
so far everything he said is exactly how you're
supposed to approach a thought process in chess
he played his idea saw what his opponent could do
worked it out and said it's good he evaluated
it and look it's happening d5 there it is he
predicted it i also thought i just looked up at
this he was trying to impersonate me or something
so i'm just looking at the sky and start pointing
every which way so i did just notice him do that
i'm not sure i'm not sure what exactly was going
on but i did i did see that well he inspires
you and you inspire him right back it's a it's a
beautiful it's a beautiful relationship he's got
to go to the middle right he's gotta the danger
though is we saw him arrowing towards a5 and c4
on the very edge of the board so that's the one
danger here um if he puts a knight in the center
i think he's doing well if he goes the other
way i i'm quite concerned um wow he does it
he does it yeah it's it's very hard to under to
figure out the attacking ideas um x2cc is using a
lot of timing oh no oh no oh no terrible move oh
no and you know it's actually a terrible oh but
you know what i realized i think pawn takes pawn
was a better move not objectively but i think for
attacking ideas it was a better move than this
because now after xcc moves his queen um it's
at least his king is safe still fine it's fine we
lost it it's fine did it earlier we'll do it again
ow did you hear that hey kara he just
said we were minus three we'll do it
again just like you you guys are completely
in sync today like but he's analyzing it now
[ __ ] it's okay
i overthought it that's what
happened i think that's one
of the best moves good defense that's a
great move wow yeah let's pull that up
if if xqc doesn't realize that knight
takes d6 as a threat it could be all over
okay and he's taken now we gotta get queen takes
yeah rubies will take with the queen for sure i
don't think there's any question about that i
don't really see how xcc is going to survive
this though because i feel like now it's shifted
the other way where basically white is the one
who has the easy moves like you can move the
rook down the pawn on d6 is also very weak
um and xcc doesn't really have any kind of
attack uh towards the white king so i i i don't
really know how he's going to pull this one out i
think most likely rube is going to win this game
is really hurting actually he finds queen b2
very nice move yeah he finds queen b2 linking
up the queen in the rook and it's is it even
how is it even m11 is it like queen takes b1
i think the computer is just crazy or no
because you can go king d7 somehow and then
survive right you sack the rook and then yeah
he's got to play queen but what a comeback huge
yeah i think rubius has been putting in a lot of
work offshore as well as the sense i get because
he's playing this very very well i mean once once
he uh once he once he's got that extra bishop
again just very very good and now no mouse slip
by ruby it's just queen b8 instead of queen b7
and um and that's game over and i expect him
to find it yeah i i think he's just taking
his time because he has it i think last game
he blundered the bishop right exactly yeah
he's maybe we can check in on his stream to see
the celebration right before or as it happens
i don't know if we're gonna be able to do that
but he is drawing an arrow to b7
he's actually not even oh no oh no
very tense he hasn't drawn it to b8
oh my gosh he got all the way there
in fact he should remove the arrow so he
sees that he can go the full length it
might just be like true that's true he might
be hindering his own vision here oh my gosh
oh my gosh he might have this is crazy he
stopped to be oh he's going the other way
oh no he missed it
all right let's pull this back
up and that is actually why
arrows help but you got to be able to remove
them also left click on any empty square that
you can't move to or oh man wow and now the xcc
finds bishop to g7 it's game on again bishop g7
and he finds it and now it's now it's uh
it's game on again this is unbelievable
he has no check positions here with
his screen whoa i haven't heard him say
that is unbelievable actually by the way you
know it's funny lovey it still says mate in 14.
not so much how i don't know it says
mate and 14 for white i i really don't
know either but it's pretty funny you can't
do that yes it needs to go upwards i mean
mind you it's that's not going to happen
because it's game on where can he go i see
here that's insane oh my gosh wait what
queen takes excuse you can't believe it
and you know it's still not over yeah it's
still not over but i mean i think again it's
oh i see it wow good move
i take he checks what what
boss man just take the bishop doesn't
matter it's like the damn bishop
she checks i block he takes i take
i need to get rid of that crossfire though asap
all right he's playing really well
king d6 and there it is it's gone
now let's see if rubios can play rook
a7 and get winning chances again or
not winning chance but try to create some
some sort of idea to keep it complicated
yeah next uc is converting it seamlessly
and he's he's he's getting amped up fine
he can still go to the right and
we can discover him think about it
lynn very nice wow
wow amazing dad let's go barbie i i didn't want
to expect anything you know uh coming out of your
opponents i just i just played my game right so my
plan was just to play my game and not like think
about his rating or his projected skill whatever
and um all of his openers i know how to transition
from from early game to mid game and i all my
pieces were all scattered and stuck in in blocks
and it opened up tons of good moves from and i
was lost i i didn't know what to do how to move
and um you know i i couldn't breathe the
whole time i was only playing his game
and i was never playing my game and uh that
stressed me out i think i only won because
um he made mistakes uh later on in his game
right because i never got to play mine so i'm
happy about the wins i'm like i'm happy but
um i think i could have done so much better
so at the beginning it was uh i i felt
like i was ahead of him like i had
many more pieces than him uh at the beginning or
at the mid match but at the late game i always
grew up because i get like confident overconfident
and then i start making mistakes and so yeah i
think that happened in both of the matches like
in the beginning uh i was like a little bit ahead
but then at the end it was like boom so but it
was really fun like like we were saying uh after
before we did like many mistakes both of us
like i did a pepeka move he did a pepeka move
and then he did a genius move and then i do a
normal move a good mood so yeah it was like i felt
like it was like he was saying like real chess so
i enjoyed it really much i started playing like
uh three months ago or something like that like
and it was also not because of queen's gambit
but it was uh because the the previous spock times
where xqc failed in six moves after that i began
watching more more test streams and it
was thanks to xqc and hikaru so yeah sweet
i don't remember that six moves i'm not sure
i like the like the variational approach here
no please don't and it's too soon it's too
soon hikaru we didn't even reach a climax
yeah with moisty critical
it was amazing oh yeah um
you